the Paradox of beauty and tranquility
hiding a coastal excess of disease and
poverty I don't think any Town should be
suffering the way that this town does
Hastings picturesque seafront is a
mustache health
walking alcohol and drug abuse is very
common in this area with lower life
expectancy in one of the most
I do drink again it's going to kill me
and I'm not ready
but a town that may hold answers for
wider Public Health we need to solve the
public health problems of coastal towns
if we're to solve the public health
problems of the nation as well
so I've always been a drinker
things anne-marie's struggles with
alcohol addiction are far from unique
I've got cirrhosis on the liver and it's
um we're not reversible I nearly died
and I said she's not going to make it
so they had to um Randall my family up
say goodbye to me
there are significantly higher rates of
alcohol-related Hospital admissions here
than the national average but stigma
seems at times to be a barrier to
broader Healthcare access
classes is addicts
they don't see the issues behind why we
start drinking we've been branded as
something different
we've not been heard
this week I turned four years two months
clean and sober wow
hardly any caffeine no drink no drugs no
nicotine I can be in person sitting over
there Darren just amazing
Workshop run by local addiction recovery
charity Ezra there are multiple Health
needs I've got lungs heart liver
pancreas nervous system all complaining
but some describe a reluctance to be
open with professionals I think it'd be
better for everybody if everybody felt
that I could tell the truth yeah I mean
it would be easier for the doctors and
easier for
everybody and Charities like Ezra are
filling a gap calling surgeries because
if they don't no one will that's the
greatest need isn't it that people need
to be accessing Health Care at the
appropriate time and we all know at the
moment that that is hard for everybody
but for clients that are in have chaotic
Lifestyles it makes it even more
difficult if they don't get the right
treatment then they will die
that's how urgent it is yeah
in Hastings life expectancies more than
a year below the national average but if
you look closer in some areas here it's
even worse
perhaps the starkest example of Health
inequality is this if you're a man born
here in central Saint Leonard's in the
town your life expectancy is more than
11 years lower than if you're born less
than 30 minutes away Inland in Cobra
Northeast for example if you're a woman
it's more than eight years lower
poor housing has also been linked to
poor health particularly rentals with
Hastings rental sector twice the average
up here is a lake
that has now formed mushrooms there's
obviously damp you can see and all the
black mold coming through the woods
rotting away my mattress has grown black
mold there we go and that's all ready
for you Rosie and her seven-year-old
daughter Ella rent privately but now
have to sleep in the lounge now she's
got asthma you've never had that before
so I think that's to do with the damp
and the mold in the property how does
that make you feel rubbish
so yeah it's not great and she could run
down the beach and everything before
without coughing now she struggles to
run around without wanting that asthma
pump
in an exclusive interview the chief
medical officer who's leading the way on
Coastal Health inequality says without
meaningful action it will worsen there
are people who move to the coast with
health problems from elsewhere so in a
sense they are taking the health
problems of the nation and concentrating
them in particular areas and we should
therefore try and concentrate some of
our efforts in those places what didn't
work in the past because obviously money
has been put into these places but to no
tangible effect
generally what's happened is each
individual coastal town has been seen as
an individual problem and of course in
one sense they are Hastings is different
to Blackpool is different to skegness
for example but all of them are probably
more similar to one another than they
are to their nearest uh significant
Inland town and what I I think we need
to now do is see them as a group and
create a solution for them at a national
level
in part across the rest of the country
but the difference here is that some
aspects are much worse self-harm
addiction smoking teenage pregnancy and
couple that with in general an older
population in the town that's a huge
burden on Health Services here and it
appears that there are less available
with difficulties recruiting and
retaining NHS and social Care staff good
afternoon surgery in fact there are
fewer nurses consultants and medical
postgraduates per patient in Hastings
under the seaside towns like it compared
to the rest of the country once they get
the training they try to move out we
have talked about the retaining people
incentivizing them to stay in this area
but those incentives have has been very
very like ad hoc the biggest cause of
the life expectancy Gap here is
circulatory disease it certainly doesn't
make me feel hopeful Chris has heart and
blood problems and hasn't seen a doctor
for over five years I worry now how
difficult it appears to be able to get
any medical treatment if my doctor was
sitting in front of me now I wouldn't
know who he was
work is being carried out to help
improve long-term Health barries
targeting child food poverty because
it's just so deprived the issues are
everything
you know in the schools there's doing PE
in their pajamas because they can't
afford the PE care you know they're
coming to school with no socks on
because the parents can't afford socks
a battle that Hastings under the coastal
towns are trying to win this is a
problem which is not going to solve
itself so it has to be tackled actively
and because of an aging population the
expectation is that if we do nothing
it'll in fact get worse
but it's against the tide of an NHS
crisis turbulent and surging Beyond
capacity Adele Robinson Sky News